hi I'm Greg Street I had creative
development at write games and I'm Andre
van Rijn I am designed director on
League of Legends and we are going to
run down every champion in League of
Legends also got those champions grouped
by the positions they often play in some
cases we had to make a call or a
champion ended up in a bit of a wet spot
and sometimes we're gonna go very
quickly because League of Legends has
141 champions jungle champions
ammulu sad lonely child or yodel I'm not
even actually sure what he is right now
he's some kind of little mummy he's
definitely sad I'm sure on that and he's
little must avoid it if alone the sexy
scary succubus later
demon incarnated by horrible feelings
[Laughter]
Elise spider lady terrifying nightmare
balance when it comes to world yeah
she's kind of a spider lady dragon he is
a guy who is looking for the best drink
in the world
Oh spillage I get upset by Gragas on
frogs picking a thinkin parkas was super
curry and his reliability it does make
for some simple place usually around
this ultimate she also makes games feel
very Sammy he walks around he throws
kegs at people repeat 4,000 times every
game graves
first name Malcolm here he has a shotgun
and a cool mustache and sometimes a
cigar he tried fighting didn't take I
mean because he has a shotgun he used to
kind of be bought way now he's a little
more of a jungle guy trucko eats the
world he's a big monster guy that gets
bigger when he eats things Diana
they called me a heretic now they are
dead moon lady nemesis sound hast friend
to Leona
she's got a good sword this big purple
Frankenstein monster dude who believes
he's a doctor
move don't go whinnies music he has
cleavers hecarim boss undead boss fast
centaur dude everyone loves the arcades
again brutal destroyed - its kind of the
league version of a druid like a plant
guy that stalks across lanes and aspects
we used to be incredibly evil until he
found a bait away his pets name is Daisy
Daisy's pretty cute
[Music]
Jarvan IV melodramatic came to be he has
a spear he jumps on people that's a
recurring motif and League of Legends
she's one about demacia yellows as well
that's one of our other recurring motifs
okay another common motif of League of
Legends is Ed lords and Cain is one I do
love the back and forth he's got with
roust though especially for us having
such a sense of humor about the whole
thing rather than buying into the dark
demonic edgy sort of things as much rust
is his scythe that also can possess him
depending on how you choose to play Kane
demon trucked in the night shift with
cousins he evolves into lots of
different things but they all have
blades and wings and he jumps on you
kindred Alam and a wolf for
personifications of death and runeterra
love the idea I don't think we quite
nailed them especially the role of wolf
really but too much sidekick rather than
fully fledged partner yeah it doesn't
feel like you're playing two champions
it feels like you're playing one
champion with a wolf circling around you
builds fun also lovely look limes
animations especially Lee sin blind monk
like some fantastic plays his lawyer
used to be so stupid because he was a
summoner who decided to join the league
meaning he was a player I don't even
know what that means
I was the thing been sick things really
interesting here because you know back
in the day the whole drop a walk down
behind somebody W torch and kick them
back into your team that was pretty
revolutionary
God named after the guy who first stop
doing it and SiC became a verb yeah yeah
now it's the sort of thing that just
cropped up everywhere even I'm pretty
average skill games the player base is
growing that much better both of at
least someone playing well in general
Master Yi he's got a helmet with like
six eyes or something
he's got sword boots when you first play
League of Legends you think there is no
possible way to beat this point and then
you never see him in high EULA
actually this year except we saw that
whole gold funneling thing which was
just
monstrous with you see everything is
true nunu and willem absolutely adorable
fini aversion nothing can roll it down
mitt instead of just running and down
mid and now people understand I hope
that nunu isn't the Yeti nunu as the boy
knocked out evil rice love his ultimate
a little boy lures pretty bland I think
he was a nightmare that came to life one
day I'd love to feed you to him
something
hola viking bro laughs i think that
should be his main skin twitch the rock
Krampus
okay okay no good no good no good
actually
turns out he originally did have
different dialogue it was recorded it
was never released it was so terrible I
was so sure on time they just recorded a
few lines okay going that's all the
thing I put that out planning to come
back to it some day back in the early
days and it clicked he's an armored
Dillo which is kind of dumb he's kind of
cool he's cool okay he has depth
perception issues cuz he's only got one
eye
he's also been one of those people loved
to play him and hate playing against him
champions I think he's got the face 240
on the guy he's a cool character but
could be frustrating because he hides in
grass and jumps out at you but of a
alien versus Predator vibe as well with
women cossacks which i've always loved
yeah they have their like hunt contest
which is super cool wrecks are one of
only two champions that don't have
intelligible dialogue and again oliver
void Campion's like ' you just where
they want to make a shock basically
she's a monstrous void space shock
[Music]
she's only got one horn she really
doesn't like her sisters she rides a
bore she's been another pro balance
nightmare she has a flail shake oh he's
evil jester dude that likes to trick you
with stuff at the same time I think he'd
create some of the best tricks to run
deception and mind games play with God
okay I don't like playing against him
and the shake one my team is always
terrible but there's something Crichton
they still got to worry about people who
please shake elephants
Shyvana the half dragon just turns it to
at Raggett sometimes it's that cheeky
dragons are cooler dragons cool I think
we gotta make an Israel joke in here as
well
Ezreal likes to kiss Jove on his leg
according to a canon
bye she's a bruiser always ready to
fight we struggled with that old must be
feeling fair and balanced volibear it
stands for armor and polar bears and
white men like to be fit there's some
really cool stuff in that but I don't
think we did a great job of it the first
time around though or the second we
should fix that
he needs an update for sure I think Oren
made him cooler in some ways
yeah sure he's actually got a
relationship that matters Sion undid
battering ram I think one of that best
VG Jews as well the little flag that he
has coming off his head if you look
close it's actually a dagger stuck in
the back of his skull gameplay wise I
think he's also one of that tanks who
does the best job of being unreliable
and therefore gets to be high impacting
and pretty skill expressive skarner
crystal scorpion said missus is people
you have two guys I work with the place
garter and I think we hold it against
them don't we have one guy who plays in
nothing bought thousands of scout again
we have a couple of those people and
they all they play as garner one who
maybe just gets cold Scout artwork that
got weird for me work less the werewolf
still tick wolf has a really cool CG
trailer
I think another of our best feed to use
or Rika didn't really lose the essence
of the champion yeah stayed really true
to the spirit but modernized on man I
don't want to stuff feel better
Zach will be Goo man more lighthearted
and not quite fourth wall breaking but
saying your characters I don't
understand that name Zach how is that a
blobby man apparently we just wanted
them to be a regular guy who had regular
parents and piltover and I called him
Zach I'm surrogacy
moving on to top lane champs aatrox
we'll always be at the start of the
alphabetical sorting alphabetically
we need an a a a champion I'm sure we
can do that well seriously I love his
update I think we probably went too far
away from some of the original gameplay
people liked about eyedrops he needed
work but we diverged about your father
he's another darken champion meaning his
weapon is taking control of him the dude
isn't important it's the weapon that
counts Camille
at first she was just hook shot right
there she was all built around hey we
have a cool idea for a champion where
she has a grappling hook that's true we
even called a hook shot yeah I think
Camille's always got a tool to respond
to whatever the enemy's doing and that's
also what people hate so much about
Camille mate would be both a pretty
popular champion especially on top lane
and a frequent ban Gary's rival to Garen
kinda similar Kitsch and I think one of
the most successful small updates we've
done in terms of taking them from super
stat cheeky and really pub stompy doing
a lot better on hiya loathsome I've got
a skill expression on cool moments I
feel like part of his original goal was
hey if this guy's in lane you're
probably gonna lose you just have to try
something else pretty bad
he or she has bangs and a pane which is
really good at stabbing people pretty
arrogant but lovely players also love
percentage from excel true damage they
love it Garon
he's kind of like Superman it's hard to
tell stories about Superman it's also
one of those standard archetypes though
that are pretty valuable in a story at
the same time Darren's still Kemp's
brush.right he's just like great general
for devasya that hides in the brush who
jumps out and spins out here I think his
relationships with the other Damacio
characters also do a bit too flashy
Malcolm make them a little more
interesting you seen demacia they are
suspicious of magic yet Darren's sister
is a powerful mage Garen is not a major
all giant metal silver falling from the
sky just pure coincidence no magic he's
kind of a pirate he's a very pirate he
did die and then he came back
I've always loved his W being yeah
remove Scooby that temporarily makes
them better and remove some appearance
from him I heard a story that you guys
are like we need one more ability for
this champion and CAD Wells like he
should have an orange to ward off scurvy
punished by Segovia almost all the time
except briefly when he eats fruit narf
he's a cute little yordle that turns
into a big yard old you think he would
be like really cute and easy to play but
he's not one to go for the yodel version
of dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde sort of
classic opposing personalities thing
allowi
not played by that many champions but
really loved by those that do play
actually really happy with how she
turned out at this point she has this
big ball that somehow summons the
tentacles I never quite understood the
metaphysics of how that works I do love
the philosophy she's got though yeah
live life to its fullest always be
moving and learning fight and eat and
other things even if I die I die in
motion I think players have this like
ship with her in gangplank or maybe that
was us we also implied that she's got
interest in Brom I know you are strong
I wonder if you have stamina Eroica
blade lady better Natha we did update to
irelia this year and again she's ended
up really strong I think the coolest
part about her design is that her - can
we see it and so she can find inventive
ways to move throughout the fight and
really take advantage of that also
thumbing meant even just farming minions
with it feels really great Jax he's so
awesome
he needs only a lantern the Kiwi has
like three fingers it's a frog find that
that's not revealed yet but oh I'm sure
he's a frog that's not canon also don't
know frogs have three fingers I don't
think Kennan lightning right
hyperactive League of Legends there's a
lot of ninjas kenan is one of them
he's one of at least in than jury ninjas
because he's little and has lightning
and loud
no stealth it's not a very good ninja
after I don't think he's a mentor at all
he looks like one of the masks when
another yordle he rides a lizard skal
was adorable
he's got the lizard also get off his
lawn klett is less adorable he kind of
comes across as yeah a grumpy old man
think he's my most lovable hiding
champions as well I loved his dialogue
but I can see you being really horrible
enough 24 a lot of people if you look at
the section that lists like allies and
enemies cloud list every champion is
[Music]
Malphite a rock his alt feels great I
think he's probably got at least
developed personality of any champion in
our minds he's like 10 times is bigger
than he can appear in game oh he's a
tree somewhat angry tree he throws
things at you the saplings are adorable
to be sure took me a long time to
realize he was associated with shadow
Isles faction mordekaiser Lord of Death
named after our a writers then
girlfriend now fiance he needs an update
[Music]
if you play NASA's you should wither and
run or just keep farming the entire game
until your team loses because you're
still farming he's an Anubis type dude
that cures ridiculously satisfying nah I
like the Q particularly two hundred
stacks Pantheon spottin I hear you like
300 it's more drawing on history but
yeah same inspirations I think he
couldn't eventually be cool in the Lord
he's part of the targa faction his old
is fine I think there's a lot of
potential through him he just needs some
work
he's actually one of the updates I'm
most excited for us to do
Renekton necess is angry brother john
crocodile he has giant blades loves to
jump in and cut you with them a lot of
Renekton players if they haven't won by
like level 5 or 6 that kind of done some
pretty good video lines to light wheat
dark meat it's all the same puppy she's
a little yordle with a big hammer
big dreams little snuggle T yeah I like
the puppy update a lot I played a lot of
repetition after we fixed her up I was
doubtful we'd be able to balance that
ultimate but I think the team really
nailed it actually quit she has a bird
doesn't really feel like she's a bird
champion yeah I think there's something
in that archetype we can do great stuff
with but the Ranger with with bird
companion or whatever we haven't really
nailed Riven Riven is a champion who's
deeply deeply loved by players who go
really deep on her little know fact
there are more Riven mains than there
are League of Legends players and I'll
tell you about it he's a urinal with a
neck suit it's got one of the most
talkative skins in the game needs a
little kick start there mechanized
Menace I love that ultimate actually
it's not quite as teamfight deciding as
it used to be
Shannon at least the ninja like a ninja
who runs around yelling he's really
tanky teleports across the map and
protects you know stealth no subtlety
I like Shane actually we tried updating
his out once to make him look tanky and
burly it was just really weird
there's like big buff ninja didn't feel
like at all
runs around pretty trolli proxy films
really different playstyle
the characters a little hard to
understand he's like some kind of
scientist of the big shield at a you
know tank of chemicals it spreads
flammable stuff everywhere with a judo
throw I think it's meant to be him
scooping people up with the shield I'm
flipping them
one of his arms is bigger than the other
angry split pusher pretty cool stuff but
he's a little - he has a lot of
potential who dear
pop man Todd bear Todd Phoenix saga
about turtle he turns out a lot of
different animals and none of them
really help him I think that's but I'm
feeling that dude's being ridiculously
strong enough a lot of the time he used
to have the best skin in the game but
then all of our more recent skins have
kind of passed it up I still love that
coming what we called out the plushy
skin ma there go we decided to make a
champion that appealed the players that
want really really gross ugly champions
we then reworked them to be a bit more
focused on beat the monstrous the
nightmare the horrifying
we gave him shotgun knees and meat
grinder in his belly but he pulls people
into yeah I think the update he's really
cool now he's still pretty niche but
yeah not every champion has to be you
know a ribbon or Yasuo and there's a
place for or got to go
Mooka I'll take on The Monkey King yes
apparently players in China are pretty
convinced that he's a thing with re
based on some fan fiction syndrome
another demacian with a spear very manly
I think his title is seneschal and
there's a story that like one of the
earlier jarvan's went to noxus to bust
him out of the arena which seems
unlikely but a yes well he's a really
polarizing one many players love him on
fly hundreds of games he's also one
where opinion varies of him greatly in
different regions we did some surveying
on this recently in North America for
example I think in terms of feeling fear
to play against players were rated him
137 out of 140 champions available at
the time by contrast in China they rated
him 23 so it's a really different takes
on things their understanding it's the
Chinese nickname for him translates as
happy wind man I don't know if he's
happy he's a wind man he's a little
despondent wind man
Iori alas poor Yorick I knew him Horatio
used to be a buggies champion of the
game he used to be a gravedigger which
we thought maybe not many players were
coming to League of Legends to live out
their fantasy as a gravedigger he's a
bit more than a gravedigger as well he's
got cool minions now and now let's talk
about Middler a colleague of stealth
he's got a bunch of trickery range of
tools Oh ball rusty cool assassin really
love the way visually her update for now
nine-tailed Fox she's a mess Dyan
meaning she's part human part animal
spirit she has a really fun cue she
likes to charm people very popular in
Korea for some reason she's got nine
tails because we're drawing on some of
the myths like they're Korean gumiho for
example who traditionally have nine
tails I believe for aliens soul he's our
David Bowie space dragon David Bowie was
one of our biggest sources of
personality reference early on we wanted
that that big really out there kind of
arrogant but pulls it off charming
personality a snow globe perfect for my
click to destroy you destroy you there's
a fun character design because we're
like what is the you know room tear and
take on you know a divine level powered
dragon it's also one of those few
champions we've managed to keep in a
really good state as a pro pocket pick
yeah some teams will run them he'll crop
up he'll that's my high impact they
don't probably get banned out for a
while right down prey gets hit yes it is
the robe our engineers had a lot of fun
and challenges trying to make that body
animate correctly because he's so long
he's begged for mercy
Olivia she is a Phoenix but in a twist
she's an ice Phoenix I think she's like
a demigod and kind of on sister at the
moment can you confirm I cannot hear
probably a biggest imbalance challenge
he can summon an entire army to fight
you I love his personality I also just
want to yell if she reassured me mr.
Rima some of the time yeah he's like a
sure 'man Emperor
you know ferrotype dude with a bird head
[Music]
Cassiopeia a snake lady another shurima
field of backstabbing but a classic
Medusa snakes don't wear boots Corki
Corki for some reason flies around
runeterra in an airplane which presents
a lot of storytelling challenges he also
looks more like a weird old man than a
Oertel he now has a bomb he can go get
to drop on a battlefield really enjoy
what that does and spamming the muscles
with result I think so pretty fun llama
echo
young arrogant cocky brilliant and vanta
grew up on the streets he has a device
that allows him to cheat time but he
might be a yordle but he looks like a
fish he throws shocks it doesn't you've
got to give credit for that according to
players we serve a frustration champions
when he's really strong
I think designers would say that -
that's fair hi Morgana yodel inventor
places turrets throw his bombs makes bad
science jokes it's funny too cuz he
didn't really used to be a yordle but
when we updated and we're like well he's
closest to your dough let's just give a
pink nose and turn that weird brainy
thing into hair and he's kind of cute
now ultimate thing f was nicknamed a
broccoli hit by some of his players cuz
the way that brain just stuck out of the
back of him Jase he has a hammer that
can turn into a gun crossbow thing and
back into a hammer really arrogant this
is what the future looks like likes to
go win his Lane all by himself all the
rest of the team's fighting somewhere
else has never been a pro balance
problem not a single time decimal he
likes to teleport into you and stab you
with his cool sword is it possible his
daughter might have come back confirm
Karthus
[Music]
every game needs to have a powerful and
dead mage fun fact beckon I think it was
beta catheters passive was that he has
immune to sleeps polymorph someone other
CC type I forget
none of which actually existed in the
game at the time so it did literally
nothing
Catarina
[Music]
she jumps around and throws knives at
you she spins she might have a famous
garden going on even though she works to
the other side probably a less tricky
deception of character compared to say
shaker tried an update to a couple years
back
and she like includin Mohammed and go to
revoke the most of them very hard to
balance her ability to pick your targets
tech high rust and then slip out of
things ease not quite unparalleled but
incredibly high the bursty deception you
know it's kind of the assassin architect
but as a mage making skins from the
blocks a challenge because she's
basically a lady with a staff so it's
hard to recognize her silhouette when
you like changed her skin into something
else something my favorite champion I'm
told I have to buff all the ice mages
only say that because she's a frost mage
and everyone thought I buffed frost
mages and well actually tried to play
her for a while to live up to the
reputation
I tried lissandra support trying to make
it a thing it's not really
the world our world will be reborn
Mel's Allah he summons lots and lots and
lots of little void things he's got that
deca he never uses for anything
Oriana a lady of clockwork a champion
everybody loves to talk about thinks
it's well-designed and nobody plays much
of the time pro picks yeah Oh always
crops up half way through well depends
up
she was strong all this time and every
new I think every every League of
Legends player has their moment I'm
gonna get really good at Orianna and
they try a few games like Oh may have
rides rework rework hey let's have a
wizard in League of Legends but let's
make him blue and not wearing a lot of
clothes what if we're still made him
really tanky that would make him easier
to balance right let's give him a lot of
abilities that only pros can really use
effectively and then an ultimate that's
even more so has good CG though but the
only power I truly have is the strength
to let it go what man so he needs to be
so lame he was like the bird mage I
think he's pretty cool now I think
there's some cool stuff in there even
beforehand but I certainly I prefer that
news why I think that passive especially
being otherwise will drag people to old
you my stuff you'll see Co allies that
feels great
he's got a demon hand Sundra she also
has balls to say one of them she throws
matching plays I love getting hit by
that ultimate another one that shows up
in pro a lot alia earth manipulating
mage she can make walls down the middle
of the map actually probably more of a
junk look at this point enough
line up a shovel see her back in bed
[Music]
tell him parkour
ng Paco hey it's another ninja what's
the fight
I think he's got that charming a little
bit cheeky personality the carbon if you
lations is really unique there's not any
other chamber that only plays like that
kind of waiting for the right card to
come out timing it correctly you can
also either make great plays or fail
horrific ly with that opening
[Music]
Victor he's one of those dudes like you
know he believes in replacing himself
you know piece by piece with mechanical
elements to make himself better this is
kind of the mad scientist but he's not
like diabolical about it man kind of a
fancy vampire
no no human Mensa totally not a vampire
it's a completely different thing he
just looks like a vampire and his blood
magic and has the name Vlad
xerath insane floating sarcophagus first
time I played xerath I went the entire
game without understanding how to use
the old dude Rex it ain't like cancel it
all the time I never was able to
actually fire the the large-scale
projectiles it's a shame it's a funnel
[Music]
definitely a most popular ninja the best
ninja
actually maybe Kelly's mom he's got like
a shadow and he's got blades on his arms
he's also one of the classic doc edgy
the ends justifies the means
brooding types he's a great villain for
a lot of the characters and leader dig
obviously the best is on champion again
Andre yeah I'm supervised here it was
the first champ I worked on by myself so
I've got a huge soft spot for him he's a
Ural that throws bombs grenade jumping
from a bunch of FPS games was something
that was really on my mind and I just
wanted to really capture that that
reckless the zany sense of fun rather
than a more serious take on explosives
Zoe not at all controversial best moment
of League of Legends is playing Zoe
worst moment in League of Legends
playing against a she's very much a work
in progress at the moment we've got
somebody looking at a bunch of things to
try and keep her strong and fun but make
her write more fear feeling experience
to play against it's like she has four
champions worth of cool abilities in one
little body
I mean she generates strong emotional
reactions for for better for us marksmen
slash ADC
- she's an archer with a bow made of ice
one of her more distinct ATC's as well a
lot of oak it is about CC and a bit of
vision rather than just straight damage
and mobility
Koechlin she's a sniper Sheriff
cheerleader like I can't I have money
besides he's got a cool hat and a lot of
belt and a lot of range
Draven welcome to the League of Draven
that phrase was actually what first got
put up on one of the whiteboards at work
when people were kicking around the
initial ideas for driving and that just
got everybody bought in and
understanding what we're trying to make
he was just kind of a lame gladiator at
first until we figured out the angle of
no he's a showboat man like he wants
everyone to pay attention to him
actually before the gladiator there was
an earlier version again which was just
this weird lizard guy who lived in the
jungle and threw axes he'll probably get
around to making him at something Israel
one of my most popular ATC's balance
challenge with that q such a cool crate
of play at the same time I feel like if
League of Legends ever kind of box again
he's a strong contender to go on the box
we've got a full official of toys and
stuff from coming out soon but his
abilities are pretty good so we didn't
need to mess the much Lucian I love
Lucian he is a badass gunslinger that
hunts down the undead to avenge his
partner who was soul was captured by
thrush yeah I love that rivalry and the
connection of demacia will Lucian's from
the shadow Isles and the law as well
he's not a happy man
jinx another really popular ADC got a
whole range of different weapons and
development names with psycho Arsenal as
a result I use her all the time he's the
example of a champion who's thematics
matched the gameplay because her passive
really encourages you to take bigger and
bigger risks which is that you know the
whole point of being James that's had a
bit of a translation Who Must
understanding when were originally
localizing details of her reveal for
other regions
her title is jinx the loose cannon this
unfortunately got translated in one
region into what's effectively jinx the
floozy cannoneer which was not at all
what we're going for
Jhin somewhat unhinged but brilliant
artist obsession with a number four
he's been about darker characters you
look at his personality like he's
clearly a psychopath but views himself
as a maestro and an artist and kind of a
you know Hannibal Lecter way his voice
is so calming book quick he's a rat with
crossbow and likes poison he was hiding
vein
I do love veins this on though I think
the degree to what she has to put
herself at risk to do anything
constantly moving around the edges of a
fight actually she's like a vampire
hunter maybe part vampire who tumbles
around and shoots crossbows don't think
she has any sense of humor
Ziya the other half of the duo of the
couple we were at least lost you she's
the bird of prey to recons bird of
paradise like he's all flamboyant and
extroverted and she's kind of you know
dark and brooding I also think she's
cool because a lot of our marksmen are
like have a gun or a bow but she throws
feather darts hi son daughter of the
void another mobile play making ID city
she fires missiles Calista I love her
story the spirit of vengeance I love as
I play a lot of supporting I love play
playing alongside her as well terms of
how my game play gets changed up new
things I can do but man she has been a
balance nightmare for us it's really
hard to play so once you play a lot of
games in there she's really good she'll
sort of shuts down believe pretty hard
and that ultimate saving her support and
lead to a lot of lack of action on lane
so I love the way she moves around with
her passive making her feel very undead
is kind of bad Genki I have this
fantastic cell phone
ball even though we usually play
the void is this like horrible creepy
place the void can be cute too he runs
around as Baxter was all about wanting
to eat things he slobbers a lot he's
pretty cute he melts your face off
misfortune pirates hunter bounty hunter
she's actually got a lot more backstory
than you would think just from playing
her a lot of the you know the the strut
is kind of an act to disarm her enemies
think we really need to update ovo at
some point watch your mouth kid or
you'll find yourself respawning at home
a lot of cool character never as we say
Justin coming across
so the warrior princess a mercenary
warrior princess
she throws a round circle thing I like
the way how old genders team comps and
there's some strong synergies there if
you got somebody like Olaf you just want
to get onto the enemy team a lot of
IDC's you know do a lot of damage at
long-range she's shorter range and has
more utility
Tristana happy-go-lucky Yodle ADC with a
rocket launcher loves to shoot things
very excitable also my favorite
character to play in mecca's minions
beerus he is our kind of prototypical
nail Archer ADC fomented backstory about
the backstories at this point he's
another one of the dudes with a darkened
weapon that kind of you know the
character is really the bow not the you
know what's left of the mortal he also
has a fairly amount of you know kind of
magical feel for a class that has a
bunch of like people with guns it's not
many people could be cool to with was
cute
and now support champions Alistair
abominable who he's a minute will think
he's Taco nyan
he likes to knock people up with his
combo and he's got that skin with the
cowbell we can just spam that noise over
and over any motorist young para para
para Mensa pyromaniac better both
haveyouseenher bear Tibbers I think
named after a produces girlfriend and
two favorite teddy bear or something big
girlfriend like to set things on fire
I love bird he just expands the universe
it's so many different ways we're making
bad one of our goals with him was to
make him a bit unknowable one of this
character that that you loved that you
were fascinated by you didn't quite know
what he wanted why he was doing things
tried a lot of pretty weird abilities
with him few of which worked out and so
now you can get birds that you know Cal
State Altamont at the perfect time to
when the enemy team the game just roam
off in weird directions picking up notes
for who knows what purpose I love Bob
the roaming support part is pretty cool
that he has motivation to leave Lane and
not just sit there and babysit as
marksman brand another farm age but he's
actually on fire dude we were update his
spell icons they were so bad the manly
support and I think what about most
warm-hearted happy nicest characters in
the game as well he's just awesome
he's a great champion he has this giant
shield it's actually a giant door that
he uses to protect his allies doesn't
use a weapon mainly about the protecting
although actually bashes people with the
shield quite a bit
[Music]
let's cry he likes to grab people but if
a weird contradiction in terms of how
his vo and his backstory go together
from memory
we actually argue about is he like a
lovable you know Iron Giant type
character or is he like a vicious troll
I mean it's dumb his dialogue was all
you know Dalek exterminate humanity time
of man has come to an end
exterminate exterminate Fiddlesticks
murderous kicker he summons crows to
peck at you this game plays not great
kind of minds we have a wild warlock
with the whole drain tank thing that
ultimate crates such high moments yeah
but crit playing getting some of those
advice expels him Lane crates such low
moments Kelly oh he used to be a
gargoyle now he's a 300 foot tall
Colossus Kael effectively an angel
October was being trolled on at the time
league of legends has angels close
enough perpetually strong can play any
role has a big sword working on a update
at the moment for both her and her
sister Morgana
Jonathan she's kind of the prototypical
magical support that keeps people from
ever getting close to her yeah tends to
shut down an awful lot of action karma I
think this something really really
interesting and the duality that come
was meant to capture both the the
strength and the combative side and the
the more reflective and protective side
[Music]
she's a Sun warrior with a big shield
that for a support likes to jump in and
stab you has dialogue lines like I will
protect you and then just goes straight
into the enemy team and starts murdering
them leaving you by yourself there's a
lot of players I think will only play
Leona by you sorceress yodel unusual
personality wise and she spent hundreds
of years trapped in some weird
dimensional something I think her like
login screen says it all we're like the
woodland creatures are running in fear
from her Lux she is a light mage she is
Damacy and nobility but is secretly a
mage which you know they're kind of me
just in demacia I think she's got one of
the most satisfying Ultimates in the
game that John Eliza I'm wanting a
satisfying last
[Applause]
Oh God fallen angel or fallen not angel
but totally an angel we think she's one
of those champions it could pretty much
play any role and I also think one of
the old champions whose kit holds up
really really well
dark nine days fun yeah we're working on
an update for that but I'm gonna change
much yeah game Templar was game plays
pretty good
League of Legends also has mermaids
apparently oh really she's one of my
favorite supports I like the you know
the diversity of her abilities she has
some healing some protection some
ability to do damage
I played a lot of Nami in Austria I'd
agree with jack-of-all-trades Nautilus
[Music]
giant drowned Titan and the diving suit
never get to see his face
Nautilus actually came from an original
piece of concept art we had there was
this weird guy in a bomb-disposal suit
we liked the bombs and we like to sue
but we didn't like them going together
we ended up splitting half of that out
into Nautilus and the other half out
into zigs middle she can turn into a
horny
gruff ancient Forge God he'll give cool
weapons to every level team fight so if
you want to play support that you really
like to murder people
yeah then do we have the assassin for
you someone gets helped by his old chair
and gold from kills he gets with allies
so he is helping he wears shark jaws
around his neck one half of a duo of
champions a couple in fact not that
we're at least the last yet another
champion had spied upon white David
Bowie
personality-wise he was first pitched to
me is like bird of paradise with his
partner being bird of prey which I
thought says it all love his Big O as
wealthy bunch of the genuinely happy to
be doing stuff excited Soraka
she's the only real healer at League of
Legends and hopefully the only one being
one of a bigger challenges over the
years too to balance I think she's an AI
reasonable but not ideal spot at the
moment
[Music]
musical support like bar doesn't talk
just different reasons you know the DJ
Sona skin I think set a new high bar for
what we were able to deliver to players
in terms of skins
tahm Kench we originally set out to mike
we want to make a tank that did stuff
different while the tanks I love how
Tolkien turned out
I love the tongue I love the Fez I love
the personality the river spirit you can
feel him living in the Mississippi River
under a bridge somewhere playing his
long em theme with his tongue he's like
a crystal paladin guy I liked what they
team did with the update to him as well
actually gave him give him a bunch of
tips on compassion on his backstory and
then we'd have a much stronger character
and much better art he looked so absurd
that's true he was one of the those most
showing the age Teemo ah Teemo I mean
some players action and everything he
stands for some people think he's worse
than that he's gotta the anti mascot of
League of Legends
he's frustrating to play against with
his poison and his invisibility and is
leaving mushroom bombs everywhere
he's also adorable some people love him
we play him straight like he doesn't a
witness not aware that such a force of
evil in the world rash one by most
popular support and also I think I first
stab at making a really different
backstory for us support somebody much
darker and then pairing that with a
bunch of gameplay they're focused on the
play making and different ways what
previous support picks it aloud whatever
I get asked like what's my favorite
champion League of Legends I mean I
don't have an absolute favorite but
Thresh is an easy one to to mention for
the way his theme works really well with
his abilities and all of his abilities
are actually pretty fun I love the way
his thing suggests that he's gonna be a
fighter or something similar and then
there's a bit of a expectations breaking
when you find out he's a somewhat
supportive character and plays a really
different role for you expect let's
actually helped us draw a new audience
of players into the support role and let
them have fun with it the lantern can
just change the outcome of a game so
much it's a really high moment for a
support character to be able to do
frontal
here's my trundle story I got him once
in an AR am game had never played
trundle before never died never bought
an item got an S a lot of it's just
about that pillow though in the creative
plays you can make him teamfight some
way you can screw people hopefully not
your allies up he is I guess a very evil
euro mage I think he thinks he's much
evil of than he is though it's also
named after a former writer who was
extremely 12 so I think that was the
height of humour we ever got to it he's
one of those infinite scaling characters
it just gets more and more powerful as
the game goes on vel'koz intelligent
void Monsta
we called him professor I beam and
development I really feel like he's kind
of come to define the void even though
he's one of the you know later avoid
characters developed we originally tried
to make him but like karma wine that
he'd have no CC on his cat and be
somebody you both have team comp around
wasn't quite able to pull that off but
he still CC lodge and really could be on
the damage I think that ultimate feels
fantastic to control as well did we
think he was gonna be popular support we
think that was a chance we're starting
to see some might just get some old play
at that point so in for those of you who
really want to play an old man in League
of Legends well not just that but old
man who throws clocks Zyra a plump mage
crates plums notice people with them she
sends like thorns out after you she has
yeah giant plants that can do tons of
area damage we originally we're
expecting czar to be more of a mid laner
but looking back I think we just missed
how strong a natural fit that kid has
with support play it's very heavy only
the disengage all the picking targets
your allies
you have to scout brush and so long lots
of video games have the trope of the
character that summons turrets or
minions and they're always hard to
balance and desirability so that was all
hundred and forty-one League of Legends
champions I hope it was fun for you it
was fun for us we'll come back when
we've got two hundred eighty two of them